what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome to another episode of media vs.
comics where we take a character from
the comic book industry who has appeared
in a TV show or a film or in some kind
of media and we compare them to their
comic book counterpart and we ask the
question which one's better the comic
book version or the media version and in
this video we're gonna be focusing on
the kingpin it's starting off what we're
gonna do here is we're gonna focus on
the Frank Miller kingpin because the
kingpin from the Netflix series is based
largely on Frank Miller's kingpin now
what's really cool about Frank Miller's
kingpin is that he is brutal he's
intelligent and he's cunning I mean he
is the villain he is the kingpin of
crime-- and there's no doubt about that
and none of this and there was no
element of this that was more obvious
than in Frank Miller's graphic novel or
a series daredevil born again and this
is considered by virtually all standards
of measurement to be the quintessential
daredevil story by Frank Miller this is
the story when Karen Page who had left
to the I guess the the partnership of a
foggy Nelson and Matt Murdock and
pursued a life in Hollywood ultimately
devolved down into a heroin addiction
and eventually into I guess adult
oriented films and when she was shot for
cash she sold the identity of Matt
Murdock now eventually the identity of
Matt Murdock made his way up the ranks
it was purchased by kingpin and kingpin
waged a one-man war against Matt Murdock
he had the bank seizes house he had the
IRS freeze his bank accounts I mean he
did it all totally waged a war against
Matt Murdock and to me this really set
the standard but the other half of
kingpin from Frank Miller's daredevil is
that he's an understanding person he's
also has kind of a softer side
especially when it comes to his wife
Vanessa
now vanessa is a really interesting
character in the realm of a kingpin
because when it comes to a relation to
him she doesn't like the fact that he's
in crime and in fact she didn't know he
was a criminal when she got married to
him which is a really big turn from what
we saw in the Netflix series but the
fact remains here that when it comes to
the aspect when it comes to the concept
of Frank Miller's a kingpin
he is the quintessential criminal I mean
he is the guy that stands the test of
time when it comes to breaking the laws
and one of the coolest aspects
that he always uses his ties to politics
to judges so on and so forth to keep
himself out of the criminal I guess out
of jail he keeps himself away from
basically being directly tied to his
actions he is in effect the Michael
Corleone of the Marvel Comics now in the
Netflix version I love this version of
kingpin I mean this Vincent D'Onofrio in
my opinion he was the star of the
Netflix show and I know it was called
daredevil and that's cool Matt Murdock
was a great character but Vincent
D'Onofrio I think stole the show I mean
he ran away with it in spectacular
fashion initially I was a little
concerned about his character I thought
he was gonna be somewhat of just a
genius criminal we didn't really know
how he rose through the ranks he was
just this hidden hand he was the guy in
the shadows we didn't really know how it
was that he came to be who he was for
the fact that he was in the shadows the
fact that people didn't speak his name
otherwise somebody who was tied into him
who was watching would kill the person
who said his name I think was a
fantastic concept to throw in with his
character it basically told us that
kingpin doesn't have to be there in
order for kingpins I guess authority to
be known by anybody in Hell's Kitchen
that I think was one of the most
important elements of his character in
in the Netflix series in addition to
that we saw the brutal side when he when
he smashed a man's head off using a car
door how hardcore is that how brutal is
that that right there I think really
gave us the dark is sadistic
do whatever it takes psychopathic
kingpin but the fact remains that with
the Netflix series one of the best lines
of of kingpin I think is when he's
sitting in the police escort vehicle and
he's being taken away by the FBI and
he's simply he goes to the story of the
man who was travelling in the the
ill-will that was set upon him and so on
and so forth and he says that throughout
his life he always thought that perhaps
he was the traveler he was somebody else
or someone other than the ill will
itself but it turns out from his
perspective he is the ill will it is in
his nature to be dark when you compoun
that with the fact that we got as we got
his absolute story as the child we got
that version where he had effectively
his dad he has beat his father to death
with a hammer to me that really
established just how dark brute I guess
uh Wilson Fisk Ingo just how dark
kingpin can get with regards to his
characters so the question has to be
asked if we have to pick one if we have
to choose between the Netflix version
and the comics version which one comes
out on top
I think we all pretty much agree here
that at the end of the day it's the
Vincent D'Onofrio Netflix version and I
bear no bones I regret nothing now those
of you guys who disagree tell me why
tell me why you think that the the comic
book version is better than the Netflix
version but well we haven't seen a whole
lot of Wilson Fisk well we only seen
what amounts to maybe half a season in
terms of actual character appearances in
the TV show his character development
was second to none his establishment as
a brutal sadistic but intelligent and
cunning villain was second to none it
was one of the some of the best
character development that I've ever
seen with regards to any kind of
superhero in the model Cinematic
Universe and I would go as far as to say
of all the villains that we've seen in
the model Cinematic Universe so far of
all the characters that we've seen in
the model Cinematic Universe so far
kingpin has to be the very best just by
the basis of the fact that at the end of
the day when it's all said and done that
he's just a man he's a guy that can be
shot and killed just like anybody else
yet somehow he appears to us as being
superhuman with that being said I'm
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
it and I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace
[Music]